I have an idea for social experiment
tell me how you feel about this for
those people who don't like America
let's say you do not like America
America is a bad country right
what if America agreed to give you
quarter of a million dollars cash to you
direct deposit in your account you don't
have to give it back quarter of a
million dollars in exchange for your
citizenship and your green card meaning
you are white American been living here
for 42 years you hate America here's a
quarter million dollars but give up your
citizenship give up your a green card
you know you can go to any country we'll
give you a one-way trip but you can
never ever come back to America over
again would you take it
apparently Americans are terrible
customer based stuff what polls I'm
seeing and I just saw Jake Tapper from
CNN who said you know independents they
may be a great day to celebrate for a
lot of Americans but there are many
people who are not happy about
Independence Day and what it means to
them okay I wasn't born here my family's
not from here I didn't come from
generational wealth but I'm very
grateful for Independence Day I didn't
know about the meaning of it until I
joined the army and I was at South
Carolina and they were celebrating 4th
of July and I saw grown men and women
crying in tears because of the
sacrifices other made for us to be free
to to complain to claim a religion
to not claim a religion to be an atheist
to be an agnostic Jehovah seven day
Christian Catholic Muslim Scientology
married not married whatever you want to
do opinions you want guns great you
don't want him no problem you want to go
together with a hundred people and talk
about the fact that America sucks fine
you want to get together with a hundred
people in tell America it's great fine
what a great country so let me get back
to my social experiment if America gave
you a quarter of a million dollars in
exchange for your citizenship and your
green card and you can never come back
to America ever again I'll give you a
one-way ticket to anywhere would you
take it
yes No comment below and share this I'd
be very curious to hear how many people
would agree to this and if they do I'd
love for
government to take up the offer and
spend 25 million bucks 200 maybe 250
million dollars actually test that hot
I'm so curious to see what happens
5 10 15 20 years later